[Music]  ma'am Miranda you're famous hey Rand a  usual just uploaded a video to the  Internet  can't wait to go home sit it's real good  baby even if no one watches your videos  I love you no matter what those famous  people on the world starting off on the  Internet  Justin Bieber Susan Boyle that cat that  bells a table when I got scared oh oh oh  it's happening it's happening  fifty-two views that's practically  everyone is right and your video has  gone viral oh oh you suck don't make any  more videos yet you people are monsters  you allistic on your teach I would never  ballistic on that go get infected this  YouTube thing is gonna watch us into my  new five phase plan for fame first  there's the Bible video television  singing career movies and five magician  sounds easy to me you know you're all  about you haters I'm not only that  something from person you may drink  that's how the models do it how's it  look amazing so are you in Alto or  soprano I'm American  [Music]